this is from daily wire also it says
turning red is the newest movie from
disney pixar that has some parents
turning red with anger they say the
children in the movie are overtly
disobedient and rude plus there are
sexual themes including the main
character twerking as a panda in front
of her mother while taunting her plus
multiple instances of the girl rebelling
against her overbearing chinese-canadian
mother to the point of being
disrespectful
the film is talented touted as a
coming-of-age sensation where the
supernatural and the mundane happily
walk hand in hand
the rod tomato synopsis says turning red
in turning red uh
may lee miley is a confident dorky 13
year old torn between staying her her
daughters her mother's dutiful daughter
and the chaos of adolescence and as if
changes to her interests relationships
and bodies body weren't enough whenever
she gets too excited she poofs into a
giant red panda
the movie's rated pg is intended for
slightly older audiences compared to
other pixar films especially since it
deals with subject matter of puberty
specifically however even considering
the target demographic some parents and
reviewers are insisting the project goes
a few steps too far and what's worse it
lacks the charm inherent to so many
other disney pixar projects i've heard
this criticism of this film
has basically summarized what we just
read there
um that it's just this obnoxious kid
disobedient to her parents it doesn't
actually have a message of course you
can portray that kind of stuff in kids
movies been portrayed many times before
but the question is what's the what's
the message at the end of it
um
and there is no from what i've been told
there is no message at the end of this
telling kids okay well actually you
should respect your family is important
you should respect your parents
that's not the message at the end in
fact the message is quite the opposite
of that
and then also apparently um so this is a
this is a movie about a girl
going through puberty
and turning red and the fact that she
turns into a
red panda is a not so subtle metaphor
for that
um and so that's part of the the theme
of this movie and then you think well
who is it actually
is this is this a pixar movie about a
panda is this for 13 year olds is that
who this is for
because when you think about pixar
movies like every other one that's been
made you immediately think okay well
this is for five and six year olds
maybe other people can watch it too and
enjoy it but that's that's who it's for
um a movie that deals with well this is
specifically about a girl going through
puberty
i don't know who is it so this is a
pixar movie specifically for 12 and 13
year old girls
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
but look i haven't seen the movie
i don't plan on seeing it
um i've heard enough just from this
that i my kids aren't going to watch it
i do put a lot of stock in kind of
parental reviews
those are the i tell you what those are
the only reviews i actually care about
the only ones that i trust and i find to
be relatively reliable
um i rotten tomatoes aggregate scores
don't really mean anything
even the aggregate audience score to me
doesn't mean much
the fact that that a bunch of critics
liked a certain movie that doesn't mean
anything okay uh the fact that the
audience broadly liked the movie also
doesn't mean anything because if you go
to rotten tomatoes look at the aggregate
audience score for pretty much any
marvel movie it's all going to be like
99 people raving about how wonderful it
is and the movie is terrible um what i
what i do care about what i do read
especially before i put anything on for
my kids if i'm not familiar with the
content myself is uh you know you go to
some of these sites and you look at the
what are parents saying about it what
are the parental reviews and i find
those to be
most of the time pretty reliable
and this is all i need to hear you know
if you've got a large number of parents
saying this is not good for kids it's
got the wrong messages it's on top of
that it's just kind of loud and
obnoxious and stupid
um that's enough for me to not show it
to my kids
and i i think we all need to be a lot
more discerning as parents what we let
our kids watch
especially when there's no real like
sacrifice in being a little bit more
discerning i think there are a lot of
parents who will just basically put
anything on for their kids and they
almost never tell their kids no when
they want to watch something
but it's i mean why what what's the
what's the downside if you're more
discerning and you tell your kid okay
well we're not gonna watch this movie
and it turns out that the movie was fine
and they could have watched it
how are they hurt by that they've still
got a million other things they can
watch it's not gonna hurt them
even if you stop them from watching
something that would have been fine it
doesn't cause any damage to them
but you let them watch things that they
shouldn't be watching and you make a
habit of that then there is some real
damage to that
and as i said it's not i think it's an
important
detail here
for me as a parent when i'm deciding
what my kids can watch
uh yeah i'm worried about what are the
messages what are the themes what are
what what kind of things are we dealing
with in this movie i'm not going to put
a movie about
uh puberty on for my six-year-old okay
so i'm i'm thinking about that i'm
worried about that
but also
just
is this
taking all the messages aside even if
the messages are fine and relatively
innocuous
is it just a stupid loud obnoxious dumb
thing
and it sounds like this movie is that
and there's a lot of kids movies that
are like that a lot of kids shows that
are just dumb loud
bright noises
or you know bright bright colors loud
noises and all that's all it is and it's
just obnoxious and stupid it yeah there
might not the moral messaging might be
fine it might be as i said innocuous
but it's making your kid dumber your kid
becomes stupider
in ingesting all this stuff all the time
this constant media diet of dumb dumb
content
and it detracts from their attention
spans it makes them so they can't pay
attention to things it makes them so
they you know they constantly need
stimulation coming from a million
different directions and all of that
that's enough of a reason for me well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content